[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le cycle de vie d'une entreprise c'est
le même que le nôtre unis les sens une
ville et enfin la mort sauf qu'il arrive
parfois qu'une entreprise censée fermer
le rideau continue d'être maintenue en
vie sous perfusion des aides de l'état
est en pleine crise qu vide avec les 300
milliards d'euros de prêts garantis par
l'état
le risque est d'autant plus présent
avant la crise en 2017 selon une étude
de la pmi la banque des règlements
internationaux sur 30 2006 remet dans 14
pays
les entreprises zombies représentait
déjà 15% en france selon france
stratégie c'était environ 5% seulement à
force de contracter ces fameux prêts
garantis par l'état de suspendre les
dépôts de bilan ou de préserver le
chômage partiel tout ça sur une crise
qui va durer jusqu'à on sait pas en fait
ces entreprises zombies pourrait ainsi
se multiplier à vitesse grand v en
contractant des dettes massif qu'elles
ne pourront pas rembourser ses dettes
qui puisque l'argent il prêtait sous sa
garantie reviendra donc à être réglée
par l'état
vous et moi si vous préférez et ralentir
voire empêcher un retour à la normale
reste à l'état de faire des choix
identifiées quinze entreprises il faut
sauver
et quelle entreprise il faut laisser
mourir tout cela pourrait contaminer
toute l'économie devenant ainsi
zombifiés est totalement dépendante de
l'état